[Musique]
ils n'ont débat sur france 24 aux états
unis on attend une décision de la cour
suprême sur le droit à l'avortement le
pays est suspendu à cette décision des
sages d'autant plus qu'un document a
fuité un document qui laissait entendre
que la cour suprême pourrait revenir sur
ce droit à l'avortement ces décisions
sont d'autant plus explosive à plus de
quatre mois des élections de mi mandat
et alors que ces thèmes le droit à
l'avortement ou encore le contrôle des
armes à feu domine la campagne joe biden
avait promis la réconciliation de
l'amérique or la bataille culturelle
fait rage et la guerre idéologique
divise républicains et démocrates
avortement le retour en arrière les
états unis fracturée on en débat avec
mes invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés une fois n'est pas coutume john
rich macarthur bonsoir vous en général à
new york on ait envie de vous avoir sur
ce plateau directeur de harper's
magazine et ses permanences 22 mai quand
ça c'est celui qu'on peut encore trouver
en kiosque à paris y compris des copé
merci d'être avec nous john rich en face
de vous il n' kunz bonsoir professeur à
l'inrs fake paris auteur de portraits de
vip l'incroyable histoire de kamala
harris merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce soir brice couturier est avec nous
bonsoir bonsoir journaliste essayiste
auteur de hockey millénium ses taux aux
édition de l'observatoire et vous faites
aussi un édito dans le point le dernier
point qui titrait d'ailleurs sur notre
sujet aux états unis bienvenue à vous en
face de vous françois durpaire françois
bonsoir historien spécialiste des états
unis auteur de la bd le dernier livre et
c'est chez glénat françois durpaire bon
on va commencer avec vous un oui vous
pouvez bien sûr tous participé
participer sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le hashtag débat f24 alors n'hésitez pas
à poser vos questions ce droit à
l'avortement pour cadrer un peu le sujet
en l'absence de lois fédérales la cour
suprême a déclaré en 1973 dans son arrêt
roe vs wade que la constitution
garantissait le droit des femmes à
interrompre une grossesse ce droit
existe tant que le foetus le foetus
pardon n'est pas viable soit vers 22
semaines de grossesse les états
conservent le droit de légiférer pour
protéger la santé des femmes tant qu'il
ne leur inflige pas un fardeau
injustifiée ça c'est ce qu'elle a ajouté
d'abord qu'est ce qu'on appelle fardeau
injustifiée et puis surtout que peut
faire la couche la cour suprême
aujourd'hui alors
tout leur jeu en fait du débat ait notre
attente tourne autour de quoi on s'était
vus il ya à peu près un mois et c'était
une fuite une fuite de la fed un
brouillon d'un first grave de la cour
suprême qui disent qu'ils remettaient en
cause en fait l'arrêt roe vs wade ça
nous a surpris on était très surprise
sur le plateau que la cour suprême aux
remettre en cause cette arène 1973
qu'est ce qui se passe depuis un mois
car c'est difficile de le savoir parce
que précisément il ya une fuite il ya un
mois mais depuis ils ont en tout cas
menacé donc évidemment vous imaginez
bien qu'on n'a pas trop de fuites alors
on essaie de deviner ce qui est en train
de se passer ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est que le juge en chef le
chief justice john roberts qui est
conservateur qui est pas un grand
partisan du droit à l'avortement mais
qui est un partisan de maintenir les
arrêts de la cour suprême il préserve
son institution 1973 cet arrêt ou la
prend dans les manuels scolaires et bien
lui les sept combats qu un des juges
conservateurs de faire quoi de dire on a
le choix entre quoi entre défédéraliser
dénationaliser le droit à l'avortement
mais lui ce qu'ils souhaiteraient c'est
de dire on de des fédéralistes pas c'est
à dire qu'on maintient roe versus wade
mais on laisse une marge supplémentaire
aux états pour qu'ils remettent en cause
un peu plus l'avortement vous allez me
dire quelle est la différence pas grand
chose lui c'est ce qui va dire à ses
collègues conservateurs en disant ça
change pas grand chose mais on maintient
le symbole de roe versus wade donc dans
quelques heures on va savoir si
effectivement la cour suprême s'il est
parvenu john roberts à ses fins quel
intérêt pour la cour suprême en intérêts
de relations publiques de dire on n'est
pas des affreux conservateurs pour riom
on maintient un symbole très fort et
puis aussi ne pas être au coeur quand
même de la politique de
de la médiatisation et la rose et le
charme et de sages au petit peu au
dessus de la société départir john rich
vous êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de
dire françois durpaire j'ai lu tout de
même qui avait trait états qui avaient
adopté des lois des lois dites zombies
ou gâchette pour interdire les ivg dès
que ce type dès que la décision de la
cour suprême entrée en vigueur oui c'est
presqu'une une absurdité de suggérer que
que robert reste au dessus de la de la
foule delà de la contre offre du contenu
de la controverse parce que
le mouvement anti avortement est très
très bien organisés ils ont prôné une
suppression de l'avortement les gars
depuis très très longtemps et justement
sur la cour suprême il ya notamment à un
certain 46 tomos son épouse est une
militante anti avortement l ennemi
depuis très longtemps elle avait aussi
rêver aussi soutenu la la la la les
émeutes du 6 janvier donc et elle était
elle et c'est la cour suprême est pourri
vraiment pourri et c'est ça qui est
nouveau par ce pardonnez-moi deviendrait
qmi a longtemps que ce débat les états
unis existe d'ailleurs vous le dites
vous même ce qui est nouveau c'est
effectivement ces trois juges
conservateurs c'est qu'il ya un vrai
débat aujourd'hui la cour suprême qui
n'était pas le cas avant oui l'auteur de
du brouillon j'ai perdu son nom à lino a
mis à l'eau à l'italie tôt c'est un
grand conservateur c'était un ses deux
héros de de la droite
aujourd'hui ils sont des gens de renault
mais maintenant ils se seront célébrées
par tout le monde a droit tout cas ce
qu'a laissé 44 5 ans parce que 50 ans a
milité et à s'organiser pour renverser
rovers oui et ça finit par marcher et ça
a marché parce que trempe bien sûr qui
sans doute pro avortement légal j'y
crois pas à ça je pense pas qu'il est
vraiment devenu un anti avortement
protestons convient
protestant convaincu il a simplement
profité de la haine la rancune
antilibérale on dit libéral aux états
unis pas gauche et il a dit oui oui je
vais nommer les ddd des juges
conservateurs ultraconservateur qui vont
finalement renversé en deux saisons
c'est ça qui change hélène kunz le sujet
est très clivant sur plus de 60% des
américains considèrent que l'avortement
doit rester légal mais 80% des
démocrates ils sont favorables alors que
seulement 35 % des républicains et
c'était pas le cas il ya en 2016 c'était
72 39 % donc ce clivage politique on le
retrouve vraiment avec ce sujet sociétal
oui c'est une clivages idéologiques et
je vois qu'on est déjà pas mal d'accord
avec le côté parce que c'est vrai que ça
le kaki devant la cour là c'est un cas
de mississipi où effectivement on veut
arrêter les avortements des 15 semaines
donc je ne pense pas sincèrement que on
peut revenir à une situation
avant vos vies weeds c'est à dire aucun
l'avortement autorisé légal sur le sol
américain c'est pas tellement ça c'est
plus mettre des bornes qui sont beaucoup
plus contraignant agir sur le délai par
exemple dont conserver une eau 22
semaines et peut-être quinze semaines
c'est vraiment comme un messie cepici
tout juste un tout petit mousse et tout
le reste dit hélène mais ça s'est
radicalisée depuis c'était à l'origine
faut bien se rappeler que les avocats de
l'état du mississippi ne demandez pas la
remise en cause d'euros vaste wade il
demandait simplement le respect de cette
loi de 15 semaines ce qui s'est passé
ces contretemps amicaux nibards est à
remplacer bruce banner guinzbourg la
fameuse progressiste libéral et donc ils
sont 10 opportunités on va aller
beaucoup plus loin et on remet en cause
doive se jouer à la wii alors c'était
très efficace vous savez le faire
lucides et ils offrent depuis une
quarantaine d'années ça c'est le travail
devant le club
extrêmement conservateur et c'est tout à
fait vrai que à en étant élu train
paille ou quand même trois juges au
niveau de la cour suprême trois sonates
c'est énorme même de l'ère obama il ne
reste plus que du juge donc quelles que
soient les tractations avec
roberts le fait est que pas que revive
armes et tout ce qui est extrêmement
opaque en solitaire va y passer donc
c'est
qu'ils pourraient agir ils vont pas
totalement ils vont pas remettre aux
états ouvriraient la clé entièrement de
ce droit à l'avortement il pourrait
alors y bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on est
plus dans les années 70 et a maintenant
des solutions médicales qui sont par
exemple
chimiques donc si vous voulez
mais sur le principe et sur l'idéologie
je pense qu'il ya quand même un problème
de restreindre à la comportement des
femmes dans l'ensemble dans l'ensemble
brice couturier on savait qu'on parlait
de l'effet trump ça vous a fait réagir
j'ai vu tout de suite c'est lui qui a un
peu creusé ce clivage est ce qu'il a il
a nommé effectivement trois juges
conservateurs à la cour suprême parce
qu'ils étaient il a derrière lui son
électorat son électorat c'est les
chrétiens évangélistes du sud c'est
l'électorat catholique qui recrute à la
fois alors les évangélistes du sud c'est
plutôt des blancs largement mais chez
les chez les catholiques que vous avez
aussi beaucoup de deux mexicains de la
tunique de la team x comme on doit dire
maintenant chez léo
cible et il est clair que aux etats-unis
le droit à l'avortement fait partie de
la haie ce qu'ils appellent la culture
ou et c'est là vraiment la guerre
culturelle qui a entre une droite qui
s'est radicalisée dans les proportions
qu'on n'imagine même pas ici et une
gauche qui est aussi grignoté par son
rauque isme et du coup cette espèce de
polarisation extrême fait que la clé de
la vie politique est entre les mains des
plus dingues comme trump lui-même dire
qui est un mac est un malade
manifestement donc là on voit bien que
le droit des femmes à l'avortement est
devenu un enjeu de cette guerre
culturelle entre l'ultra droite et ce
qui reste de la gauche et je suis cramé
au passage que effectivement c'est très
localisés si vous prenez le missouri par
exemple qui a restreint déjà le droit à
l'avortement dans de grandes proportions
vous faites 24 kilomètres au delà des
frontières du missouri vous avez une
clinique dans l'illinois où vous pouvez
pratiquer l'avortement donc ils n'y
arriveront pas les conservateurs
simplement cette hausse il qu'on n'a pas
posé la question c'est qui organise
cette fuite et j'ai lu dans la presse
américaine beaucoup de choses ça peut
être très très bien du côté des
conservateurs pour tester voir jusqu'où
on peut aller trop loin mais ça peut
être aussi des côtés des jus de gauche
qui sont inquiets de voir l'évolution de
la cour suprême donc le jeu politique
est franchement malsain quoi qu'est ce
que vous en pensez c'est mal georges
andrique ce qui se passe ailleurs juste
pour ajouter parce que c'est très
intéressant ce que vous venez de dire
sur la gauche le ski grèce la gauche
parce que la gauche est complètement
effrité c'est fini la gauche est fini
il ya ya ya ce qui reste la gauche ce
sont des outils de la machine dont
on va on serait en désaccord très
rapidement parce que je blâme à obama
surtout de n'avoir pas fait un effort de
codifier de renforcer
provisoire avec
alors il a besoin d'une majorité au
sénat au début de son mandat il a le
vent en poupe il était vraiment très
très
il aurait été à la hauteur je pense que
nous arrivons sur ton b et c a cessé ses
typiques des démocrates nos jours qu on
se replie sur la cour suprême on blâme
les radicaux de la droite dont le fait
rien vraiment je vais bientôt n'est
presque je suis d'accord avec rihanna
cox ici parce que d'emploi pourquoi est
ce qui ne l'a pas fait
mais puisque l année à l'autre en jeu
qui s'appelle l'obamacare et il a mis il
a tout misé sur l'obamacare inhabituelle
sur ce coup là et aussi il ya maintenant
coin douzaine d'années vous l'excusé un
peu quand même quand même beaucoup
auraient ce qu'on aurait pu imaginer
on en sera là sur vos vies reid c'était
dans l'air vous allez voir un joueur des
féroé mais il ya une douzaine d'années
quand obama était dans son premier
mandat c'était quand même
et quand je vois des images je
m'interroge sur combien de personnes qui
manifestent ne sont pas allés voter
parce que on est sur des taux de
élection extrêmement faible donc les
mêmes personnes qui se heurtent et qui
sont extrêmement choqués par ce qui se
passe je m'interroge saison pris la
peine de voter est ce que ça veut dire
que c'est la droite qui est en train de
gagner cette guerre culturelle
c'est à dire aux états unis la plus
complexe que ça parce que ce qui là on
est en train de parler de la cour
suprême donc on n'est pas en train de
parler de la droite on en train de
parler de neuf personnes
mais ça va oui mais donc ça veut dire
qu'on parle pas beaucoup de ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il ya un autre débat
aux états unis derrière ce débat de
l'avortement c'est le débat de la
constitution c'est le débat de gens qui
disent cette constitution à 200 ans à
l'époque on était un petit pays
complètement recroquevillé sur le
nord-est on dépend des des esclaves on
était des hommes blancs c'est plus du
tout le même pays et surtout c'est je
termine cette idée puisque vous me posez
la question c'est simplement que on peut
se dire que il ya un chiffre qui est
quand même incroyable c'est les
présidents républicains ont nommé 15 des
derniers
juges à la cour suprême ils ont gagné
uniquement 5 des votes populaires lors
des quinze dernières élections donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya là si vous voulez un
gap démocratique considérable la cour
suprême ne représente pas le pays vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure de deux tiers
des américains sont hostiles à ce qui va
se passer demain ou après demain c'est à
dire le plus vraisemblable la fin
d'euros versus wade mais encore
si je peux ajouter c'est pas simplement
la faute de la cour suprême et le
système et 20 15 on est tous d'accord
que le système américain a des trucs
insérait dedans qui empêche la
démocratie et sen t bien sûr fait exprès
par le père fondateur vous voulez pas de
démocratie directe on voulait que ça
s'éloigne du peuple mais avons donc
c'était moi il était pris en otages
n'est pas plan fait en tout cas un orgue
est le vrai fait un grand compromis pour
donner plus de pouvoir aux états et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on dit
quand les etats unis c'est singulier en
français ce devrait être avant c'était
du real il ya ces deux publics n que
c'est devenu ce singulier aujourd'hui ça
redevient pu rial donc c'est tout ce
sont ces logiques résultats oui c'est un
peu logique c'est cette une pression
mais en même temps je voulais gagner la
gauche encore oui depuis la gauche parce
que juste très à gauche de ne pas avoir
fait un effort de
combattre l'idéologie de la droite avec
leur propre philosophie morale on fait
pas de vieux sophie moral chez nous
parce que finalement c'est un pays
protestant on était à 50 % les
protestants au fus affiché mais vraiment
c'est un cetain et pourquoi est ce que
la gauche alors c'est un pays intolérant
et très protestant et au lieu de 2,2
vraiment combattre les idées de dire
parler des choses
les femmes qui meurent à cause des
avortements puisqu'un problème social
raconte constant des femmes ayant
recours à l'ivg et vivent sous le seuil
de pauvreté aux états unis et les femmes
noires hispaniques sont sur représentés
aussi avoir la sauce hd des billets à
new york pour ce faire
m pourquoi est ce que la gauche ait pas
de mal à lui parce que là ça veut dire
que c'est la droite qui gagne déjà sa
vedette les institutions sont fausses et
aux états unis regardez de vous on est
con évoqué à l'instant le fait que les
recettes sont les états unis ciel que
chaque état des états unis représentent
envoie deux sénateurs au congrès or vous
avez certains états qui sont totalement
sous peuplés d'autres qui sont
parfaitement surpeuplée donc on va
arriver très prochainement dans les
années qui viennent à avoir un sénat où
60% du sénat représentera moins de 30%
de la population et ça et comme par
hasard les états qui sont surpeuplés
sont des états très blanc est très à
droite est très conservateur donc on
voit bien qu'il ya un blocage comme par
ailleurs toutes les lois nécessite 60%
au sénat on voit bien que la majorité
populaire la majorité démocratique n'a
plus l'expression en réalité n'a plus le
contrôle de son propre pays donc on va à
un moment de blocage démocratique très
inquiétant pour ce pays est
effectivement mais comme c'est une
fédération il faut l'accord des
différents états et chaque étape pèse 2
sénateurs qu'ils soient encore une fois
très ou sous peuplés donc c'est air
institutionnel vous êtes d'accord
entièrement d'accord avec moi mais c'est
pour le point si on ne fusionne et le
caroline nord et sud 6 ont fusionné les
dakota nourriture ici le washington
décide de venir l'état et avait donc ses
grands électeurs aura là ma foi ça sur
le paysage politique sera contenu
regardez vous savez moi je suis de la
californie 35 millions d'habitants de
sénateur au montana c'est comme quand
même comme de mental à
mettre en place un type ce type de
réforme devra être fait à limite pour
cette génération il faut voter des
choses qui prend en effet éloigné des
prochaines élections parce que sinon
soit jamais d'accord mais je reprends
juste pas question de john rae que je
reviens à voir votre point de vue là tu
es ce que ce sont ces ce que c'est la
droite qui gagne dans cette guerre
culturelle aux états unis a jamais
encore
jeux de mains jeux d'esprit que c'est la
gauche qui perd
c'est la gauche qui perd c'est pas la
droite il ya
donc l'amérique est de plus en plus
conservatrice mais bon vous savez tous
les noms des gens d'âge de sondage des
sondages démontrent qu'il ya une
majorité solide pour l'avortement légal
ya au t1 et à 60% pour le droit de faire
de se faire avorter donc ce n'est pas la
société
mais c'est la représentation c'est sa
représentation pourquoi la gauche ne l'a
pas fait au moment de bama déjà parce
que c'était plus un problème
l'avortement c'était il ya eu avait un
million quatre cent mille avortement
1990 en 2017 il y en avait plus que
862000 avortement et
93% des avortements pratiqués aux états
unis étaient effectués avant la
troisième semaine je vous rappelle que
la loi de mississipi dit
ultraconservateur ses quinze semaines
donc c'était plus un problème ce qui
s'est passé c'est que donald trump est
arrivé et lui s'est pas attaqué
uniquement à l'avortement il s'est
attaqué à la contraception qu'est ce
qu'on a vu depuis donald trump le chief
il est très simple 2020 930 1000
avortements on est pratiquement à un
million d'avortements depuis donald
trump c'est à dire que donne un train
par n'empêchant le planning familial et
en empêchant le retour la contraception
a précipité vers la solution de
l'avortement notamment les femmes des
classes populaires qui bien se sont
retrouvés face à des grossesses non
désirées qui ne pouvaient pas avoir
accès à la contraception
voilà le rôle des conservateurs au cours
de la dernière période
chose qu'on pourrait dire c'est que le
cou de s'accrocher aux etats unis c'est
assez hallucinant c'est quinze vingts
1000 $ par part par accouchement alors
quelqu'un de pauvres qui est qui qui qui
qui tombe enceinte par hasard comme ça
n'a aucun espoir pour s'en sortir et les
gens et la gauche
mais pardonnez moi mais aussi si donald
trump a réussi ses dessins
viens d'évoquer je viens d'évoquer
françois durpaire c'est que il ya
certains ont répondu à cet appel entre
guillemets de donald trump de certains
c'est la lotte la toute petite minorité
les dix quinze vingt pour cent des
radicaux républicain qui a pensé que qui
pense bien que l'avortement c'est le
meurtre même et donc donc très
nostalgique d'une amérique n'a peut-être
pas réellement existé et ça existait un
peu de temps et ça existait il ya
plusieurs centaines d'années reste quand
même sur cet imaginaire collectif qui
est ce une nostalgie ce quelque chose
qui n'est plus mais ils ont une force
morale
pas véritablement maison la capacité de
présenter leurs arguments en tant que
la moralité la morale ça c'est côté
religieux des états unis religieux et
encore protestants évangiles mais great
games nous voyez sur l'image pardon de
vous parliez mecs de 14
il ya aussi beaucoup de catholiques
silencieux qui sont très heureux de voir
les protestants et les 30 pistes nation
prenant le dessus donc c'est l'alliance
maurice couturier convention sur les
trônes piste qui finalement réagissent
quand même de manière très ils
réagissent en tout cas ce qu'a voulu
faire donald trump et écouter les trams
piste ils nous ont montré le 6 janvier
qu'ils étaient prêt au coup d'état qu'il
est prêt à prendre le pouvoir par la
force qu'ils étaient prêts à refuser le
résultat des élections démocratiques
donc on voit bien que c'est un pays qui
est au bord du gouffre qui est vrai on
se rend pas compte ici parce que c'est
la plus ancienne et la plus magnifique
démocratie du monde celle qui a inspiré
de notre propre déclaration des droits
de l'homme avec sa déclaration
d'indépendance mais aussi
tocqueville avait montré les etats-unis
sont le laboratoire de la démocratie
dans le monde c'est la première
démocratie quand on voit l'état de
maladie
gravissime dans lequel est cette
démocratie dans lequel vous avez 60 %
des électeurs de trump qui pense qu'il a
gagné les élections et qui s'est passé
malgré la commission dans quel réalisme
ans avec ces auditions qui vous aider
ces gens qui ont pris d'assaut le
capitole vous voyez que ce pays est au
bord de la guerre civile j'ai écrit ça
dans le point en janvier se payer
véritablement world bord de la guerre
civile et nous mêmes qui voyons la
polarisation arrivé de manière
inquiétante dans notre propre ressemble
assemblée nationale nous devrions nous
inquiéter de ce qui est en train de se
passer et on sait que ça peut arriver en
france amour sur l'autre sujet clivant
tout de même c'est celui du port d'armes
après notamment la tuerie dans cette
école primaire de val d au texas était
le 24 mai dernier qui a fait 21 morts
dont 19 enfants depuis le début de
l'année déjà plus de vingt mille
personnes sont mortes par arme à feu aux
etats unis selon le site geudens
avant-hier un adolescent âgé de 15 ans a
été tué et trois autres personnes dont
un policier d'ailleurs blessé à
washington par balle après un concert de
rue john rich est ce qu on retrouve là
les mêmes clivages que pour l'avortement
oui et encore il faut parler des droits
des individus parce que là c'est sacré
chez nous et encore une erreur
qu'on commises par les forces pro
avortement au pro avortement légal c'est
de te poser tout sur l'idée du droit de
la femme absolue de se faire avorter et
c'était un droit individus et c'est un
peu pareil aussi à la situation avec le
port d'armes parce qu'on se dit enfin
chaque individu a le droit de se
défendre c'est pas ça rien de rien ça
c'est le deuxième amendement oui au
xviiie siècle vous parler bien sûr du
cantonnement des soldats britanniques il
fallait se protéger contre les
envahisseurs
mais aujourd'hui c'est tout baser sur
cette idée radicale de du droit de
l'individu et 5 et je pense que les
défenses province avortement ont commis
une grosse erreur
de ne pas parler de la des coûts à la
société des enfants nos désirs et les
femmes mutilées etc on parle uniquement
de moi j'ai le droit de faire ce que je
veux avec mon corps une heure ce qui est
intéressant c'est que je suis tout à
fait d'accord mais c'est pas une c'est
pas la date
justement le droit à porter une arme
sans qu aucun contrôle et sans au 6e qui
sont contre le droit à l'avortement ça
se présentait très bon la perdrix sont
aussi pour la peine de mort la peine de
mort mais il ya plein de choses qui sont
un grand combe et saveurs partie de
cette guerre de culture que vous avez
bien nommé où effectivement on trouve
des choses extrêmement incohérent et
très incongru aux yeux du monde mais
c'est quand même accueil vous savez
devant la cour suprême hier d'autres cas
qui risque à tomber juste au moment de
contrôler bwin c'est un cas à new york
où on dit il faut quand même avant
d'avoir une arme dissimulée on vous
demande de remplir un formulaire et de
dire pourquoi vous devrez avoir ce
talent et ça c'est de trop donc et un
procès devant la cour suprême à la qui
va être décidé pour dire ah ben non
deuxième amendement deuxième amendement
donc aucune limitation on voit là on va
écouter tout de même l'acteur matthew
mcconaughey qui avait lancé lui un appel
pour un contrôle de la régulation des
armes c'était justement quelques jours
après cette tuerie à ayew velde et lui
les texans d'ailleurs on va écouter
nous avons besoin de vérifier les
antécédents
nous devons augmenter l'âge minimum pour
acheter un fusil à air 15 à 21 ans sont
les moins nous avons besoin d'une
période d'attenté avant la pause section
de ces fusillades et nous avons besoin
de lois sur le contrôle des armes et des
poursuites mais pour ceux qui les
empruntent françois durpaire l'en a'
texan acteur connu donc un qui prône à
certains contrôles très limité pour nous
français puisqu'on parle de passer de 18
ans à 21 ans le droit d'acheter un fusil
automatique me semble-t-il donc et même
sans ça risque de ne pas se trouvaient
pas ce qu'est un projet de loi
aujourd'hui trans partisan qui est donc
au congrès je ne sais pas très bien où
ça on aime et c'est à peu près à peu
près ça qu'il
déposerait déjà ce que le projet avec
eux viennent dire hélène on en a pas
beaucoup parlé en france est important
de remettre un petit stabilo sur ce
qu'elles viennent dire c'est à dire
qu'on est aujourd'hui la cour suprême
sache s'achemine vers une interdiction
pour les états de limiter le port
d'armes donc le débat français il est
complètement à l'ouest fondé en train de
se dire est ce qu on va un jour
réglementer la ce qui se passe aux etats
unis c'est la cour suprême qui est en
train d'imposer aux états de
déréglementer ça va se passer dans
quelques semaines donc c'est pour ça que
vous voyez les les débats sont pas les
mêmes aux états unis et est ce qu'on dit
et ce qu'on dit en france là on retrouve
évidemment ce qu'on a dit sur
l'avortement c'est à dire qu'on a une
cour suprême un sénat très largement peu
démocratique parce que des petits états
avec deux sénateurs qu'ils font là bas
fonds de la balance et même si on arrive
alors ç'a changé quand même tout un 21
ans parce que dans les écoles par
exemple changerait tout ben oui ça
changerait tout pourquoi je vous donne
un chiffre
les 18 21 ans et 4 % de la population
américaine c'est 100% des tueurs de
masse dans les écoles en fait ils ont de
18 à 21 ans ce qui tue dans les écoles
donc ça limiterait au moins dans les
écoles le fait que le chargeur si on
attend 21 ans ben oui parce que ce sont
des postes à redire à ce sont des post
ado malheureusement vrai parti ont
l'impression de massacrer leurs
camarades de classe alors qu'ils ont
sept ans et qui n'ont pas simplement
évoluer dans leur tête si on parle plus
du tout de l'avortement d'ici la fin je
voulais quand même dire une chose de
l'avortement en parler alors ce qui est
très important c'est que le diable se
loge dans les détails il ya un angle
mort dont on parle jamais c'est l'accès
à l'avortement des femmes pour des
raisons médicales pourquoi c'est
important parce que des états même des
états très conservateur je pense par
exemple à l'arizona vont dire ok on
interdit l'avortement sauf sauf en cas
de nécessité pour sauver la vie de la
femme est alors la faisons un peu de
débats philosophiques à quel moment on
sauve la vie de la femme vous imaginez
médecin donc à quel moment les litre de
sang et quel moment je joue alors je
vais en prison si je si je sauve la vie
de la femme et je vous donne un chèque
parce que tout à l'heure vous disiez les
femmes issus des classes populaires les
femmes noires hispaniques et
amérindiennes c'est trois fois plus de
décès pendant qu'elles sont enceintes
que les femmes blanches aux états unis
premier pays peut-être du monde ça c'est
un chiffre donc ça veut dire que vous
imaginez la conséquence de ce qui va se
passer demain ou après demain quand
reversus chouette sera abolie alors on
va revenir sur les sur les armes en tout
cas j'aimerais qu'on écoute donald trump
maintenant parce que lui il était donald
trump lui en mai dernier au
rassemblement de la nrl au texas
s'étaient d'ailleurs il me semble aussi
une semaine après ce terrible tuerie de
nouvelles des sommes à l'écouté
nous avons besoin d'une refonte de la
sécurité de haut en bas dans les écoles
de tout le pays
chaque bâtiment devrait avoir une entrée
unique éventuelle chez freshfields
devrait y avoir de solides clôture
extérieure les détecteurs de métaux si
l'utilisation de nouvelles technologies
pour s'assurer qu'aucune personne ne
peut entrer dans l'école avec une arme
ou un appel à l'aide
d'autre part les portes des salles de
classe doivent être renforcés pour
qu'elle puisse être verrouillée de
l'intérieur
à bâbord et surtout d après chaque école
en amérique devrait avoir un policier ou
un agent de sécurité armés prêts à
réagir
ce couturier c'est ça qui vous fait dire
qu'on est au bord de la guerre civile
quand on lit votre os alito moi aussi
des chiffres 80 % des électeurs de biden
pense que les et les élus du camp d'en
face sont un danger pour la démocratie
84% des électeurs de trump pense que les
élus démocrates sont un danger pour la
démocratie et derniers chiffres vous
faire trembler 400 millions d'armes à
feu circulent aujourd'hui aux états unis
quand vous pensez que la première guerre
de sécession qui s'appelle guerre civile
a fait je crois 650 mille morts pour un
pays qui compte est très peu d'habitants
à l'époque imaginez ce que serait un
bain de sang si l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche en venaient aux armes
2e 2e deuxième chose que je voudrais
dire sur les armes à feu il faut
comprendre la montée à la mentalité
américaine compte contrairement à la
nôtre c'est qu'elle ne fais aucune
confiance en son état que beaucoup de
gens y compris pas seulement les
libertariens mais beaucoup d'autres y
compris à gauche estime que l'état est
un danger pour la démocratie que donc il
faut s'armer parce que le jour où on
pourrait prendre les armes si on avait
un dictateur au pouvoir
autre chose vous avez aussi beaucoup
d'armes à feu en suisse il n'y a aucun
meurtre en suisse tout va très bien donc
on voit bien que c'est qu'une question
culturelle bien sûr la possession de 400
millions d'armes à feu dans un pays
2 300 millions d'habitants est une
absurdité est pas d avis un nom aux
sigles et les ménages voient leur nom
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
pas tant la question des armes à feu
c'est la question de leur contrôle en
suisse tout le monde a une arme à feu
mais elle est dans un placard la clé
doit être à part les videmment les
enfants n'ayant pas accès le contrôle
par l'armée est très sérieux mais on ne
tue personne oui donc si je penserai à
part dans le moquer parce que sa vie des
employés ça prouve bien que c'est
l'école parce que là nous les médecins
mandela icône des armes à feu ont eu des
drames et au-dessus légiférer les six
ehpad a vraiment mais vraiment le seul
pays au monde le sait la presqu'île
vérité suisse en port d'armes c'est les
états unis et le deuxième au monde en
port d'armes par habitant c'est le yémen
est un gars qui est en guerre comme on
le sent bien oui mais john rich oui à
l'aider pour dames c'est tellement
culturel je ne sais pas comment si
vraiment on peut s'en défaire et au fait
tu t'es monsieur qui parle dans la
terrine j'ai trouvé très intéressant
trempe il est extrêmement discipliné on
y passe le papier elie mérite nous lui
aussi par les narines moi j'aimerais
vous savez dans notre concret aux états
unis qu'on soit obligés d'afficher qui
contrôlent ces sénateurs ce serait très
intéressant vous savez comme dans les
matchs ont été obligés de dire non mais
on le sait non non non parce que même
côté démocrate et je le rencontrais
d'accord avec vous on n'imagine pas que
nos sénateurs puissent être influencés
par pelé nairas ce mec directement les
fabricants dans quatre ça c'est un débat
d'il ya cinquante six ans là il n'y en a
plus moyen aujourd'hui de financer les
campagnes j'en ai pas souvenance est pas
directement par les fabricants d'armes
aujourd'hui et les dents sont anonymes
le problème c'est qu'ils ne peuvent pas
être
vrai ils ne peuvent pas être juste quand
tu parles moi j'ai trouvé ça incroyable
que macquarie a dit
le 10 mai présenter un nom lac
saint-louis n'ont pas de revenus de m
lui est incapable de dire que quand même
c'est incroyable que déjà les ont accès
à ce genre dans six villes de l'est
des vingt mille morts par an on est
prêts aux états unis c'est terrible on
est prêt à perdre vingt mille de nos
compatriotes pour cette industrie parce
que l'amendement le deuxième moment est
sacrée c'est sacré
deuxièmement concrètes derrière cette
cette obsession avec les armes à feu et
c'est soutenu pas seulement par le nerfs
nra et par les droitistes
fou furieux s'est aussi soutenue par les
libéraux de hollywood parce que bien sûr
que tu est culturellement on il ya
toujours le loup solitaire dans les
films de hollywood qui se vengent contre
tout le monde et c'est célébrer ces
fêtes et dans l'est dans les films parce
que ça ça se vend très très bien
enfin film est un film mais moi je ne
vais pas
vous pouvez regarder tarantino
et la guerre culturelle s'émeut neige
est floue c'est tout n'est pas un film
vous parlais tout à l'heure qu'on se
méfier de l'état aux états unis ce qui
n'est pas un film c'est que lors du
massacre au texas des parents ont
attendu une heure la police qu'est-ce
qui a fleuri et pas parmi les droitiers
comme vous dites mais paris parmi les
familles famille en disant pourquoi on
nous a pas laissé une arme les policiers
n'avaient pas le courage d'y aller on y
serait allé on aurait sauvé nos familles
absents voyez c'est faux pas non plus
caricaturer ce débat le débat il est
parfois ça peut être des hispaniques qui
votent démocrate ou pas etc il ya des
gens qui sont capables de dire veut
légiférer qui achète une arme pour leurs
familles un mot générique ans quand
brice couturier parle de guerre civile
vous et non j'y crois pas non non je
pense pas qu on est sur le point de deux
dernières de cession une nouvelle guerre
de sécession parce que encore je reviens
au dos au parti démocrate sont
n'ont pas le courage vraiment
d'affronter des républicains donc non
pas guerre de sécession parce que les
démocrates sont des rengaines n'y a pas
de lincoln est en guerre
qui peuvent qui dirait vraiment
de groupes extrémistes cavage
mais
je me sens d'un livre bellerose tard
c'est une historienne belle barbara
world elle estime que pour qu'une guerre
civile éclate il ya trois conditions un
que l'état soit affaibli qu'il ait perdu
sa crédibilité
ce qu'elle appelle la no cratie ensuite
qu'elle appelle le fonctionnalisme c'est
à dire l'idée que à la place des combats
idéologiques d'antan vous avez des
combats basés sur l'ethnicité
l'appartenance culturelle et on est en
plein dedans avec la politique d
identité ensuite il ya le dès que le
déclassement cirque eu un groupe i dans
un groupe culturel possédait le pouvoir
en réalité c'était les blancs aux états
unis est en train de le perdre et comme
il est en train de le perdre en 2040 les
blancs seront minoritaires sans la
première minorité des états unis sur le
plan démographique comme ce groupe est
en train de perdre le contrôle comme si
vous voulez un petit peu comme les les
sunnites en irak quand quand saddam
hussein a été viré et que les chiites
sont devenus majoritaires quand ce
groupe dominant perd le pouvoir il veut
se venger et ils refusent absolument le
système démocratique parce qu'il est
plus majoritaire et qu'il le sait et ça
c'est déjà donald trump l'assaut sur le
capitole le 6 janvier c'est exactement
ça c'est le sentiment des blancs qui
sont qui savent qu'ils vont perdre la
majorité sur le plan démographique et
donc qu'ils vont la perdre aussi sur le
plan démocratique et donc je pense que
les conditions réunies pour une guerre
civile sont là il ya un autre bouquin
c'est celui de stephen march qui est
interviewé dans le point de cette
semaine un auteur canadien aux annexes
civil war qui explique comment comment
la guerre civile a éclaté aux états unis
john rich et vous parlez encore du du
personnage joué par michael douglas dans
ce film dont je suis obligé
en colère
parce qu'il a perdu
je connais un petit peu c'était un grand
libéral de hollywood alors on finit un
grand progrès s'il s'appelle ce film en
super g oublier ces deux noms mais c'est
vraiment
guerre civile
il y aura plus de massacre de gens tués
par exemple on n'a pas besoin d'attendre
2040 connaissez déjà minoritaire un mot
sur ces élections qui approchent ces
élections au mit mandat
françois durpaire joe biden je reprends
ce que je disais au début de cette
émission devait être le candidat de la
réconciliation alors là on voit qu'il me
campagne extrêmement dure avec des
clivages donc on vient de décrire dans
cette émission est ce que est ce qu'on
peut dire que de toute façon les
républicains ont gagné la
lecture des élections primaires la soie
sont assez difficiles madone plutôt
évidemment davantage aux républicains ce
qu'ils les démocrates espèrent alors
c'est absolument cynique c'est que la
décision de demain et d'après demain
parce que c'est l'émission est bien
construite c'est lié à l avortement les
démocrates ont décidé ne vont pas parler
trop du port d'armes assez qu'ils
allaient parler du port d'armes ils ont
décidé qu'ils allaient tout misé sur la
question de l'avortement en disant
envoyés non pas des députés et des
sénateurs démocrates mais envoyer des
députés des sénateurs prochain ils vont
défendre le droit à l'avortement ils se
sont dit que c'était vraiment l'horizon
pour eux pour une raison simple c'est
qu'ils se disent six américains sur 10
sont hostiles à l'abolition de roover
suède deux tiers des américains ne
souhaite pas qu'on remette en cause ce
droit à l'avortement donc on va tout
miser là dessus et vous regarder je vous
allez voir vendredi quand je dis vous
dit ce qui se passe à la fin de la
semaine jeudi va y avoir la décision
reverse souhaite va être abrogée et déjà
le parti démocrate a prévu une bb plein
de clips sur la télé américaine financée
impayés des clips sur internet des pubs
sur tik tok massa partout sur cette
thématique là qui met en en boucle les
républicains et les propos les plus
odieux des républicains est donc la
salle est bâtie via programme des
banlieues les femmes éduquées des
banlieues qui peuvent faire pencher la
balance mais est ce qu'ils vont gagner
on a parce que de l'autre côté les
républicains c'est sur l'économie ils
vont tout miser sur l'économie la face
miser sur l'inflation et sur le prix
simplement à l'essence il sera
évidemment c'est plus puissants
générique c'est vraiment ça va être le
débat autour de l'avortement qui fera
peut-être la différence
il ya déjà eu des élections locales aux
miches dans le michigan où des candidats
démocrates au gagne et on gagne et dans
une circonscription jamais gagnée par
des rêveurs des démocrates alors c'est
ça commence à changer
la donne mais en même temps c'est très
cynique de la part des démocrates dans
ce qu'on fait pas encore jeudi ont fait
part de l'arrêt du mans on ne compte pas
la folie de la droite on parle pas des
vrais enjeux on est vraiment la zad la
femme a le droit absolu de se faire
avorter point final
j'en ai encore d'accord parce que c'est
vrai que mon conte est plutôt
extrêmement affaibli et il ne se rend
pas compte des enjeux ils sont très
faibles de ce point de vue les justes
encore une dernière akaki devant la cour
suprême et ça concerne les élections on
est à un point où ce n'est plus qu'ils
votent c'est qu'ils comptent les votes
oui on est un énorme problème parce que
la cour suprême va légiférer pour voir
si parce que il ya encore un challenge
point dieu
entre le 4 septembre
et il l'a 15 décembre qui avec car en
challenge à l'élection trompe et à
chaque fois des juges même c'est parfois
si propre et juste où les juges
républicain trompent pas et nommé
énormément de juges et sont hostiles des
soleils de comptage est bon et là ça va
être ce n'est plus un juge local qui
décide les juges de chaque état ça va
venir au législateur alors là on ne
compte surtout des votants
soit parce que ce n'est plus les élèves
choisissent des élus savaient des élus
qui choisissait est biaisé en fait
absolument à son d'état de droite qui
sont offerts républicains qui sont en
train de passer des lois limitant
réalité le vote des minorités par toutes
sortes de moyens comme ils l'ont fait
aux livres
de jim crow dans les accords du dans les
noirs avaient quasiment interdiction de
voter dans le sud limitant le lac saint
lô et puis surtout le contrôle lecomte
qui qui qui décide vous savez là la
limite la cour suprême pourrait décider
que le candidat élu par les grands
électeurs n'est pas élu c'est c'est
possible donc donc donald trump le
gagner même s'il a perdu avec moi si la
cour suprême fait ça
parce que rob et un moment on parle de
bienne
la rance de robert son de robert leçon
très compliqué c'est un type qui joue un
jeu très compliqué il essaye vraiment de
neutraliser les radicaux mais 6-3
expliquer ce qu'est ce qui a fait dire
le lendemain de la décision par ça mais
on en dise on a simplement donné aux
états leurs droits minimaux rodial de
faire leurs propres lois il va pas
jamais à admettre que qu'il a permis une
régression
extraordinaire parce qu'ils nous font sa
renommée création
banal peut gagner là ou pas oui chaque
animal encore je vais gérer un peu
d'espoir parce que le parti républicain
est fracturée très
fatigué non les repas qu'ils récupèrent
va perdre parce qu'ils sont fracturées
il fut démocrates aussi
je suis un des seuls dans mon camp qui
pensent que les démocrates ont des
chances à retenir leur majorité en
novembre parce que à cause des fissures
programme en titre up dans le parti
républicain il ya une vraie dispute qui
t'en vas voir les votes
dans ce cas il est en guerre avec avec
mes cadres le chef luis henao chef
qui est
très farouche sur la question du
département il a reculé il avait devant
l'addition de le brouillon
on attend en tout cas cette décision de
la cour suprême à vous l'aurez compris
merci beaucoup de jeunes avec macarthur
d'avoir été avec nous merci hélène
cousseau merci brice couturier d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir et merci beaucoup
françois françois durpaire merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
demain à 18h 19h 10 pour le débat est
avec toi sur france 24